vous avez jusqu'à 10 sliman parce que
dans une interview à télé loisirs on
apprend que le chanteur slimane adore
faire l'amour en musique et pas sur
n'importe laquelle ils adorent faire
crac-crac en avons laissé se mettre au
chaud
[Musique]
et me grandir il m'a donné la chana
guérini me mohamed
vous avez donc c'est sa chanson où c'est
surtout son angoisse et chandeliers
[Musique]
on y va les chandeliers si j'étais jeune
mais alors à l'ancienne marvin gaye
jean-michel mais moi j'ai pas envie de
me relever tout de trois mines donc je
fais sur le requiem de mozart sur 50
minutes comme ça le change quoi
ah bon
comment gagner il est vierge
c'est comme mon petit frère j'imagine
c'est la famille quoi vous croyez ça
mais moi j'aime pas la musique moi ça me
la coupe directe il faut ça vous la
coupe mais voilà la bande à rabat
[Rires]
ça vous la coupe guy bâillon n'écoute
pas le savoir à n'y rien du tout moi il
faut y aller direct et guy mongrain se
révèle une bride soraya non-match bas de
gamme donc tu passes a fait une très
bonne
c'est la vie c'est comme ça et
j'embrasse slimane parce que je suis
invité à dîner chez lui non bah si vous
restez polis vous savez que vous allez
[Applaudissements]
si l'usap unique et qu'il enlève son
bonheur gilles verdez sapé comme jamais
de guignol
on verra pas possible ou fait d'accord
ça donne envie
ah ben oui vous et isabelle moi fan des
années 80 samedi
non
parfois ils étaient bien plus aura mis
un peu comme quand tu fais l'amour que
l'idée mondou d'ousmane au sepa cela tu
veux qu'elle a down est humide musique
n'importe quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je crois que ça donne envie à très bien
s'ils ont bien compris que c'était sympa
ouais t'as tout compris
géraldine maillet chansons romantiques
et peine soit et carpes riscle du caméo
le che battisti non mais là frère tu te
prends
on est tous là voilà tu prends un
benzema béninoise arena
mozart toi non oui mais non sur requiem
de mozart moi j'adore bosser sur le
grand amour de la musique classique lui
c'est vrai bach mozart schubert requiem
de mozart très beau on l'avouera grand
bien ordinaire un merci merci barret
baja richard qu'on envoie à maxime
moi je mise sur une chanson qui regorge
de sensualité s'appelle coconut water
coop